what does it take to break through on
youtube are you creating content but
it's just not being seen
well in today's episode we are going
into part two of what i like to call the
clarity equation and we're talking all
about youtube goals
clarity on your content and doubling
down on getting you
seen on youtube my name is heather
torres and you're listening to the think
marketing
podcast and if you're new here we
release a new episode every single
tuesday
so i recommend and encourage you to
subscribe wherever you're consuming
this content like i said this is part
two
of a series that we're doing called the
clarity equation
and if you've not listened to part one
yet i highly recommend
going back to last week's episode and
consuming part
one we talked about overcoming objection
there's
three main objections to getting started
and going all in
on youtube we talked about understanding
your reasons
knowing why you're doing this and who
you're doing this for
and then we also went into who is your
who we talked about who's your target
audience and how do you reach them
on the platform and i'm excited because
today we're going even
deeper we're talking about goal setting
what are your youtube
goals we're also talking about creating
your simple
content strategy i call it the napkin
strategy
and we're diving into that and then
we're talking about the five ways
to multiply your success we're ending it
all out by talking about your purpose
on youtube so we're gonna just dive
right into
the middle of the talk then i'll come
back on and i'll let you know
about a free class that we have and
we'll do a full recap
over everything that you've learned so
far and i've got some additional tips
for you
after the content we've defined our
objections
we know the reasons why we are in
business
we know who we're in business four
and now we need to define the goal
where are we going where are we supposed
to be at the end of this journey what
does that look like what's the next
step that we need to be at what's the
next level in our business
what's less but next financial level the
next customer level
the next you know whatever your goal is
you define that for yourself
but we need to define what's the goal if
we don't
know where we're going if we don't know
the destination
how are we gonna know when we get there
you know we don't just
get in the car and just start driving
and then just decide to stop somewhere
usually
usually there's a map right like we know
we're going from here
to grandma's house in here right there's
we know the stops along the way
if you're anything like me i like to
plan like every single stop i like to
fill
everything in but you know that
destination and
if you're in business and you don't know
what the goal is
well how do you know if you're going to
get there how do you know
if where you are is where you need to be
so we need to define that goal and
here's a study by the dominican
university of california they said 42
you are 42 more likely
to achieve your goals and your dreams
simply by writing them down on a regular
basis so yes i know that you know
new year's comes once a year we write
down those goals like well i want to
grow my business and
i'd love to get more customers and i
want my etsy shop to be awesome but you
know what
that's not actually a goal a goal
is tangible a goal has a number
or has a ending point or has a
destination
i want to start a youtube channel and i
want that youtube channel to be to a
hundred thousand subscribers
that's a goal so you need to define it
and you need to write your goals down on
a
regular basis on a regular basis
they can't just stay in here because you
are more likely to achieve them
when you're writing them out so this is
what i want you to do
tonight your homework is to write out
your goals
it is so important to know
why you're doing it but you also need to
know
where you want to go and here's
something i want you to know
your goals matter
your goals the ones you set for yourself
they matter it doesn't have to be your
husband's goals it doesn't have to be
your sister's
you know best friend who thinks you
should be doing this no no
it's your goal you define it and then
you achieve it
so now we've defined our objections we
know the reasons we're in business
we know who we're serving we know where
we're going
and now we need to start creating some
content
because just like mike said the more
free content we can start to put out in
the world
the more customers we will actually
attract
if they don't know where you are or how
to find you or how you can help them
they're not gonna know that you sell
something
right just like mike said when he said
he was able to start selling
on his shop because he made a free video
that's what we need to do and we like to
not over complicate this when we're
coaching clients we want this to be
super simple so i need you to get your
pens ready because this is what your
content strategy is going to be
are you ready for your 2019 content
strategy
yes okay good just want to make sure
you're awake and ready for it all right
here you go
this is your content strategy
you're going to create your content
strategy
on a napkin you remember that like
you're at a restaurant and you're like
oh i got that idea and you like write it
down you get that piece of paper out or
like the back end of a check because
that's all you have
that's what your content strategy is
going to be
you're going to write it out on enacted
and here
are the two main pieces of content that
you need
you only need two you need main
content and then you need supportive
content
you need main content and supportive
content
once you define what your main content
is
your supportive content is to do exactly
what that word says
support the main content so here's what
we do
we recommend that you have a show on
youtube
we recommend you have a show on youtube
why because youtube is a search based
engine and sean's going to get up after
me and he's going to go through
youtube for you but we recommend that
you choose a platform
online that people who are asking
questions
they can find you on the other side of
their questions
so you want to pick a platform and we
are huge huge huge on your main content
being youtube being video form and then
you want to choose your supportive
platform you want to choose your
supportive
platform now you're going to create a
video on youtube
and then you're going to post a
supportive piece of content
on one of the other platforms
don't get overwhelmed you don't need to
choose all four platforms you need to
choose
facebook instagram linkedin or pinterest
now if you are growing and you have a
team then absolutely start going to more
platforms but if you are a solopreneur
if you're doing this thing by yourself
you do not
need to be everywhere on the internet
you need to be in two places
on youtube and one other platform so if
your business is going to be running
advertising you want to be targeting
people on the internet
facebook might be your option and here's
why because you can say
in your advertising i would love to
target
men who love woodworking and also make
over a hundred thousand dollars a year
you can do that facebook advertising so
if that's the type of business you want
to be in
then facebook is it if you're a crafter
or you need to show
your craft instagram might be the place
you want to be
that's more of a magazine style platform
now this one is uh
amazing linkedin if you are a person who
needs to speak
to decision makers then linkedin
is where you need to be if you have a
business where you want to be the person
who helps the decision makers buy
your products linkedin is where you want
to be making your supportive content
and then lastly pinterest now pinterest
is unique also because
it is a searched based platform
i don't know if you're anything like me
but i
lived on pinterest for about a year
because that was an amazing thing
you could just pin pin pin all day long
and you could make your life and it
would look so pretty
but here's the thing it really drives
sales
pinterest is a search based platform so
when someone's thinking about
how do i crochet a blanket they're going
to
two places youtube
pinterest that's where they're going to
figure out how to do
that craft so that is your napkin
strategy
you are going to do a show on youtube
and you're going to pick one supportive
platform now the question probably is
well how many times do i post and what
does that look like and
oh not right all those questions are
starting to come to mind here's the
thing
don't over complicate it make it
simple i'm going to post one video a
week on youtube
and i'm going to post one time a day on
that platform
that's it you're gonna start there
that's where you
start if you walk into this this content
platform
and this content strategy and you're
like okay and you post seven times a day
on facebook and you do two things on
this i need you create seven videos a
week and you go live over here and you
do this over there
then how when are you gonna have time to
run your business
right so we need to start it simple
these are like building muscles you have
to work your way
up to posting more and more
and then you think what type of content
do i post the type of content
that your customers want to see mike was
starting
with a camera that wasn't even at 480.
what i didn't believe that
right but he was posting what his
customers wanted to see
so you start testing all social media is
is a testing ground you post something
here and you ask him hey did you like
that
you post something here and you say hey
did you like that you post something
here
and you say hey did you like that yeah
that pattern was
i post something and then i ask them
it's called social media folks let's be
social
let's start asking our customers what do
you want to see did you like this video
do you like this kind of thing do you
want to see more of this what type of
things do you like
start asking them questions and then
you'll start to figure out exactly what
you should be posting
for your business so we have now defined
our objections
our reasons our who and our
content strategy and now we're gonna
multiply
all of that by action
can you say can you say actually just a
little louder
great because that is actually what's
going to move you forward
all the other things are great we can
write down on our papers all we want
right we can
watch videos and we can pretend like
we're gonna move ourselves over because
we went to this and we did this and we
do that
but actually what it's gonna do it's
gonna
it's gonna have us avoid this the hustle
the work
we gotta actually start to put in the
work on all those things that we wrote
down
right because your business doesn't just
grow you actually have to
take action and you don't just have to
take a little action
you have to take massive action massive
action all right so here are my five
steps that we coach people through how
to take
massive action one
we need to define the outcome where are
we going that's our goal
so we've defined how do we take massive
action we gotta define
where am i trying to go okay i wanna get
a youtube show
okay i wanna get a youtube show that's
what i'm gonna do all right number two
we need a brainstorm
this is my favorite part this is where
you get to like get your cup of tea
and you get to sit down you journal out
your favorite pen you're like all right
i'm just gonna write i'm gonna
brainstorm everything what all do i need
to do
everything this isn't where you hold
back this is where you just go you write
and you write and you write and you
write
you're like all right i need to get a
cover okay and i do this all right well
i should interview this person i
need to do this right all those things
you write down everything
and then you shorten that process
if you are trying to get to that goal
it's not going to be the fancy things
that are going to get you
there it's going to be taking massive
action and i remember when
i decided to run my first half marathon
and i was so excited because i was like
i'm gonna do this i just had a baby
and i was like i'm gonna get that body
back that's what i'm gonna do okay so
i'm gonna run a half marathon
and i've never run before i actually
hated running
so i don't really know why i decided a
half marathon was the way i was gonna do
it but i was like
whatever that's what i see all these
other girls doing so i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna run a half marathon
and so this is what i did i went to
target
and i was like um that's cute
and then so i got the best outfit right
then i was like yes i got the outfit
okay
and then i was like um well i don't
really have running shoes
so i've got to go try on running shoes
and so i went to the running shoe store
and you know they put me on this
treadmill and they were like yeah okay
oh yeah okay so you've got like kind of
flat feet so you need these kind of
shoes and i was like well i don't really
like these
do you have them purple and they're like
no we have to order them and i was like
okay you have to order them that's cool
all right so it'll be a week okay no
worries okay
so i got the outfit and i got the shoes
and i was like well it's kind of hot
like it's hot outside i don't really
like running outside because i actually
don't really
like running and so i should probably
get a gym membership
right i should get a gym membership so
um
so i went to the gym and i sat with the
guy and you know he walked me through
and he's like you could do this month or
this month or a year and i was like i
don't need a year
i'm only training for a half marathon so
let's not go to a year
a commitment all right and so um that i
had the outfit
and i had the shoes and i had the gym
membership
and then i was like what time do i run
okay well i gotta work from nine to
three and then i gotta take keely here
and i gotta do this okay so
okay so i'll start training when do i
start training
oh uh three weeks from now i have an
opening
okay so i'll start training three weeks
from now so
um i did all these things right but
here's the thing
i actually wasn't running i wasn't
running at all
how do you get to the goal of running a
half marathon you run
right you put on your shoes that you
already own
you put on your headphones you rock out
to beyonce and you get on that track
that's how you start running and so i
wrote down
all my brainstorm ideas all the things i
needed to start running my half marathon
but what i actually needed to do was
just
start running so yes the brainstorming
is important but then we need to get to
the next step which is
how do i shorten the process what is
actually the thing
when i look at this list what is the
thing
that's actually gonna move me forward
and then we need to get rid of perfect
i see so many entrepreneurs holding back
holding back because they need it
to be perfect and perfect
is just the excuse that i am scared
perfect is a facade
we all know that it's never going to be
perfect
so i want you to write this down i
am going to start
messy i
am going to start messy
you know why because you just achieved
your goal
right it's good you're gonna start messy
it's not gonna be perfect it's not gonna
be the way that you want it to be when
you first start
i can tell you so many times
when you just want it to be perfect and
you're like
you know what i am going to start messy
and then you just do it you take action
and the last thing you're going to do
when you take massive action
is you're going to remember your reasons
why am i taking massive action why am i
saying no to going to cancun
why am i not doing these things that i
really think i should be doing but i'm
really staying up
late and i'm just pounding the coffee
it's because
you have reasons for doing this it's
because
you know that if you take massive action
that a year from now you could be in a
totally different place
all right so we have now defined our
objections we know our reasons
we are know our who we
have our goal we have our content
strategy
we are multiplying that by massive
action
and we are going to have the answer to
our equation we now
have a plan you have a plan
you have a plan for dominating with
video heather what about the camera
i don't care you're going to start
that's right heather i don't really have
time that's okay
you're going to start there we go so we
now have a plan
we know are the objections to time to
money to skill
we know the reasons we're in business we
know who we're in business for we know
our goal
where we are trying to go we know the
content
main content supportive content and
we're going to take massive action
and remember this is not easy but it's
simple
it's all in that simple equation right
there
you have it in your notebook right now
you can start taking
massive action today
on your dreams
and the other day we took our family
on a kayak trip and this is really
special for me because
in the last 60 days we've brought
another little one into our home
you saw three kids on the screen there
and it has taken us 10 years
10 years to bring three kids into our
home
i'm sorry 10 years to to bring a third
into our home
i was told at 18 i would never have
children
that i had a condition that it was gonna
be hard
and that i would lose babies and i
lost babies and then i had two
beautiful babies and we knew that having
another baby
probably wasn't in the cards for us and
so
we are a family of faith and we
prayed and we prayed and we prayed
for another child because i know that
our family
is supposed to be bigger than two i know
as a mother
that i'm supposed to have multiple
children arms full
and i only had two which i was so
grateful for
but for our family we didn't know how
we didn't know how it was going to
happen or you know what what this
journey was going to look like for us
and so when we got a call to say yes
we said yes and we brought another
little guy into our home
we don't know how long he's going to be
here but we're gonna
love him while he is and
this week was our first weekend
where we were able to as a family
do my favorite sport which is kayaking
and i got to be in the kayak with my
little guy
and kayaking is such
a unique sport and i say sport because
my husband is in the audience and we
argue
that kayaking is a sports not a leisure
activity
because if you've been kayaking raise
your hand if you've been kayaking before
that is some hard work right
so we argue back and forth but i'm going
to say sport honey okay so
we are on this adventure we are out on
the water doing my favorite sport
and it's me and our little guy in the
kayak
and you know it's supposed to be a
two-person kayak but i mean it is a
two-person kayak and two people are
supposed to be rolling but really it's
just me
with an extra 60 pounds uh trying to row
and i love kayaking because you're so
close to the water
you're like floating on the water and
i love solo kayaking in this and since i
had him with me
to experience this together and you know
when i was out on the water we were out
on lake mead
and i'm rowing and i'm rowing
and i'm rowing and
got me thinking that this is kind of
like
building a business just you in the boat
you may have passengers on board
but you're the one doing the rowing
and every time you push through every
video you create
every new product that you create it
gives you a little bit momentum
a little bit more right and you keep
rowing
you keep rowing and you're like i want
to go all the way out there
and it's far and you're just going
you're not a speedboat you're just going
you're just rowing and you're rowing
and you're rowing and that's what this
experience
going online building your business is
going to feel like
you may be able to rest right i know i
need to when i'm
kayaking my shoulders get a little uh as
i need to just kind of set it there for
a minute
but then what happens boat starts to
slow down
if you're not driving the boat
if you're not rowing
it's going to stop no one
is going to make your dreams come true
other than you you have
unique gifts and talents and experiences
that make you so unique that make the
thing that you are bringing
to the world completely unique
there is no competition
you
have greatness inside of you i believe
this
i believe that you would not have come
to las vegas you would not have left
your businesses
and your families and your home you
would not have come here
if you did not already know right
you already know it's in there it's
right in there and i believe that you
have greatness inside of you
you are braver than you believe
and you are stronger than you seem
and you are smarter than you think
so that is the clarity equation and we
ended
on p p is all about the purpose when you
add all of those things
up and you multiply it by action you're
going to get the clarity you're going to
have the purpose for what you're doing
on youtube and that is how you succeed
when you lay that foundation
when it's not just about the titles and
the thumbnails but when it's really
about
understanding the underlying pieces of
building a business on youtube
that is when you succeed and after
you're done listening to
this episode i highly recommend you go
over and listen
to our think class which is
our free youtube class at
thinkmasterclass.com now what is this
class this class is all about
learning how to do youtube the right way
this is part of a training that we do
inside of our academy our paid academy
and sean candle the ceo of think goes
deep into the three secrets of
how to be successful on youtube as well
as diving into
how do you get noticed you know i think
it's really important
that we understand that this is
different the youtube now is different
than the youtube then
and there's more people and more
competition so how do you break through
well we teach you not to play
checkers on youtube but how to play
chess
which means having the right strategy
knowing the right videos
and knowing how to break through which
is critical
on youtube so if you've not listened or
watched that class
definitely go to thinkmasterclass.com
so you can listen or watch the class
all right so we have now broken down the
entire clarity equation what do you need
to do next
what step of the equation are you on do
you need to figure out your objection
do you need to write out your reasons
how about getting rid
of perfect i know for me that is my
biggest struggle all the time when it
comes to taking action
even creating this podcast today i was
overwhelmed i was
stressed out i was worried about was
this going to be right and was i going
to say the right thing
but every now and then i just get
reminded by our think team
that it's not about being perfect it's
about getting the content
out it's about being authentic it's
about saying what's in my heart
and by helping you with the things i
know that you need so
what do you need to do next where are
you on this clarity equation
and have you figured out the goals that
you have for being on youtube
it's important to know where you're
going it's important to reverse engineer
and it's important to make sure
that you're not just creating content
for content's sake but you're creating
content that's going to make a
difference
so if you've been encouraged by today's
podcast if you've gotten value from
today's podcast
i'd love for you to share this with a
friend you can take a screenshot right
now
share it on social media either tag
myself at miss heather torres or
tag shawn at sean cannell and
we'll see it and maybe we'll share it on
social but i'd love to see
what was a big takeaway that you had for
today you can share that with
us on social media or if you got value
you can also
share this with a friend that's a lot of
sharing but i just want to encourage you
that if you've gotten value
and you know someone else who needs this
as well send this podcast to them
we are here to make valuable content
that's going to help you go further
on youtube it is so important to us to
help you understand how to win on
youtube
and lastly i want you to know that i
believe in you i believe you can do this
i believe that you have a mission i
believe that you have people that you
want to reach
and i want to encourage you that you can
do this if a mom of three
who couldn't figure out how to turn on a
camera can make this happen
you can make this happen too you don't
need permission you don't need anyone to
tell you that you are
right for this you already know it it's
already inside of you
so i want to encourage you to get to
action
take action take what you've learned in
this clarity equation
and apply it to your youtube business
thank you so much for listening to
today's episode and we'll catch you in
the next episode